can we all agree for a moment that anime
is gotten pretty damn good in any given
season now pretty much everyone is
guaranteed to find a handful of shows
that appeals to them which are pretty
good quality I mean this season we got
my hero be star's babylon hoshi no sora
or a tsuki cautious hero no guns life
i'm not forgetting dr. stone and villain
saga being carried over from last season
that's a pretty strong lineup which just
seems like the norm nowadays so it
should come as no surprise that the only
shows I'm up to date and have
religiously kept up with is SEO and
assassins pride wow I didn't realize
your taste with so [ __ ] gigaku
random comment to respond surprisingly
to the man that openly endorsed domestic
girlfriend as of late I think I've
cultivated this reputation as they go on
YouTube that likes and celebrates trashy
anime I don't know how honestly just
kind of came out nowhere and today I
just wanted to ramble a bit about how it
got this way why it's kind of half a
meme and half actually true and why as
counterintuitive as it sounds you
shouldn't always feel so pressured to go
out and find good anime this is doctor
trash love or how I learned to stop
worrying and enjoy bad animal
probably the thing I love the most about
the medium of anime is just how wide and
varied it is I've been watching anime
for a pretty long time now and I'm
surprised even myself by how many shows
I've been able to enjoy in just about
every spectrum and genre even though the
main reason I got into it was just to
see some big muscly dudes scream and
punch the [ __ ] out of each other animes
provided me with such a perfect vehicle
to expand my horizon and explore new
facets of what I find entertaining
there have been shows that have pushed
the boundaries of creativity in a way
you just don't see anywhere else and to
this day I've not experienced anything
like that honeymoon period when you
first discovered anime every new show
was a new experience a new discovery
about what you could find enjoyable and
the possibilities seemed endless
through this journey I found shows I
love shows I hate shows that are so
weird
I still can't comprehend whether the
emotion I felt towards them counts as
enjoyment and show so God or they made
me want to go home and commit either guy
but I feel that does come a point after
seeing enough that you kind of get anime
you get the intricacies and the tropes
you get what makes each genre tick you
see the nuances and what makes some
shows better than others you've seen
that critically acclaimed classics and
understand why they are so well
respected you see what makes good anime
good and bad anime bad but most
importantly you understand what your own
tastes are and once you reach this point
I find that people mostly go in one of
two directions either your tastes have
been forever changed and you can't enjoy
the same things that used to tickle your
fancy or you regress to that same
bright-eyed newbie you could find the
simplest cliche [ __ ] entertaining and I
remember the exact goddamn moment I
realize which direction I had taken
because it was when I first watched r-mo
major spoilers for the ending of war emo
if you really care about that now this
may come as a surprise to many but there
was a time I thought I would hate or emo
aka my little sister can't be this cute
because it seemed weird back when only
season 1 was out my initial impression
was man I really don't want to watch
some weird incest shits but to my
surprise it turned out to be an
entertaining look into otaku culture
through the cynical eyes of an older
brother who had no interest in it with a
brother-sister relationship that
actually seems like a brother-sister
relationship yeah I know Heinz laters
hilarious
everything but I'm being totally serious
I got surprisingly invested in it and
then season 2 happened and the series
shifted from this slice of life comedy
to more of your typical harem anime
where every girl started falling for the
main character it started to turn into
everything it had previously been
satirizing which put many people off but
for some reason I was still very okay
with it and then knew the ending
happened and he chose his sister and I
thought to myself man I initially didn't
want to watch this because I was afraid
he was gonna go this direction and here
we are now so where the [ __ ] am I still
okay with it this was not only the exact
point when I first realized that I was a
[ __ ] the ditch in it but also that
even though I could tell there were so
many problems with the direction the
show went as it started to appeal to the
lowest common denominator I still wasn't
above enjoying it the spy the fighter
went down the more generic harem routes
I was secretly glad it did even if it
did have the opportunity to make a much
more meaningful statement about her taku
culture as a whole and my desire to see
a tsundere as the winning anime girl
apparently trumped that little awkward
fact that they were you know once I
realized this the Giga Kai knew was
never the same again I threw myself back
into the dumpster I was born from and
haven't found my way back out since what
I learned is that despite having brought
into my tastes and gained a deeper
understanding of what makes good shows
good it didn't stop me from gravitating
to the same surface level [ __ ] that
appealed to me as a newbie when I didn't
know what bad anime was and yeah I know
I'm using the term bad anime loosely
here but please don't worry too much
about the semantics of what that
actually means people normally associate
bad anime with things like using an
abundance of tropes and cliches having
one-dimensional characters or having an
uninspired story that does nothing to
really push creativity or say something
unique and if you've seen enough anime
that's totally true but I've often found
myself wondering what makes certain
animes such popular guilty-pleasure
shows why does something like highschool
DxD seem so universally loved when on
the surface it just seems like a lot of
tits and yeah I mean it's just a lot of
[ __ ] tits and I think it's because
shows like these are so good at
understanding how to appeal to a very
specific target demographic even though
to anyone not in that demographic it
just looks like basic fanservice trash
if you like highschool DxD you know
exactly
you like highschool DxD even if it's not
exactly for a reason you'd lie to your
parents about which brings me back to
assassin's pride I'm just a sucker for
the cliche underdog power fantasy
stories as shallow and predictable they
may be probably because I grew up as a
scrawny ass nerdy wasn't the most
popular kid in school and I can feel way
more empowered here than I ever did back
then because that [ __ ] stays with you
and something like assassins pride is a
show that excels at scratching that very
specific story itch even if Bry pretty
much every other standard it's just a
generic adaptation of a generic light
novel with generic characters and though
I would never actively recommend this to
a wide audience there are a few aspects
I can say certain people would
definitely enjoy if you were looking for
this type of story this is a show that
is so unapologetic and how many tropes
dumb cliches and nonsensical
developments it can ham fits into a
story that it does this 118 becomes this
beautiful car crash you just can't help
but admire kind of like what era manga
since they did to the Yamoto genre
that's right this is basically the era
manga sensei of power fantasy shows
don't quote me on that and you know what
it's probably this exact mentality which
was the reason I found myself go through
a bit of a nice acai phase could you
tell I know have helped to propagate the
idea that a lot of ISA Chi look and feel
exactly the same but when you look past
the surface you can see that a lot of
them actually do have their own unique
appeal and even some of the most generic
looking ones can do something unique
enough to retain my interest the reason
I ended up finishing Ken Jong imago a
few seasons ago despite trashing how
uninspired it felt was because I kind of
found it interesting that the reason the
protagonist was Opie was because he was
the only person with knowledge of
science from our world so he managed to
apply this to the magic systems in a way
no one else could really comprehend the
spacing marriage of science and magic
was a subtle enough difference that I
could still find enjoyment sitting
through the exact same story beats I'd
seen a million times before sure that's
not exactly a big enough reason to
convince anyone who doesn't like Issei
Chi to watch it but it was enough for me
and I'm guessing this this reason why
Issei Chi is still thriving despite the
perception that a lot of it just feels
the [ __ ] same this is what it means
to be Issa Chi trash for some the final
form of an anime fan is being able to
recognize and appreciate truly great
shows with the ability to quantify what
makes them so special but for me it's
being able to do that but also knowing
you can make a four-hour around
breaking down while this trashy anime
sucks ass yet still being able to enjoy
the spite of that and I can respect any
person who has that ability okay
congratulations king uh it took you
years to discover that you do actually
have [ __ ] tastes um so what exactly made
you feel like telling everyone about
this so like I was saying I feel anime
is good right now
like pretty [ __ ] good I don't think
there's ever been a time in my fandom
when I've literally had seasons I
couldn't keep up with all the shows that
sounded interesting yet I don't know if
I've been the only one who's recently
gone through this phase when I was so
paranoid that I was wasting my time when
watching a new show is this really what
I'm in a mood to do right now is this
the best show I could be watching at
this exact moment is this the best way I
could be spending my time instead of
just trying to get absorbed in the
experience I was worried that there was
something new or better I could be
watching that I would constantly be
second-guessing if I had made the right
choice to watch it and I think this is
less to do with having watched too many
anime and morph just how much choice
there is nowadays have any of you ever
wanted to chill after a hard day's work
and then go done [ __ ] decision
fatigue just scrolling down your Netflix
or steam library I spent more time
deciding what you want to do instead of
you know actually doing something oh my
god why is there just nothing to watch
this is how I felt scrolling down the
seasonal chart sometimes I honestly
think we've been spoilt with not just
the amount of choices but the amount of
good choices we have and it doesn't help
that I have this irrational fear of
missing out so I found this huge problem
for me when I first entered the seasonal
cycle is that I would find myself what
she shows I wasn't in the mood for but
did so anyway in fear of falling behind
or missing out on something good which
made me just enjoy everything less and
it remained this way until I fully
accepted that I'm never in my life gonna
be able to catch up to everything I want
to and the reason that took me so long
to realize is because it didn't always
feel this way okay so small little
tangents I have a confession to make I
have not seen Full Metal Alchemist
original or brotherhoods I know I know
just hear me out so there was a time
when I legitimately thought I would run
out of good anime like that was a
in fear after watching a few hundred
shows that there was this finite spool
of anime I would enjoy and I was nearing
the end of the road I was finding less
and less shows that really appeal to
what I was looking for and newer shows
just didn't excite me as much I was
scared that there would be a day where I
lost this passion for this medium so I
took Full Metal Alchemist
a show I knew I would love I knew I
would get obsessed with and shelved it
purposely didn't watch it saving it for
a day when there was no new good anime
coming out and I needed a reason to
regain faith in the medium this was
complete [ __ ] of course now not only
did that day never come but at the point
where out now I don't have the problem
of worrying that I'm gonna run out of
good anime I have the problem of finding
enough time to watch all the good anime
out there and now I have a whole patreon
discord service worth for people who
just pay me so they can hurl abuse at me
for depriving myself of one of the most
basic and most well respected anime hey
guys how you doing right now there will
always be something good to watch your
plan to watch list is an endless abyss
that you will never reach the bottom of
and will only continue to grow with
every season and that's only if you
watch anime that doesn't include games
movies or books which by themselves have
exactly the same problem and I think
this is why for a while bad anime became
infinitely easier to watch there was
comfort in the predictable and familiar
with the knowledge that I wouldn't have
to invest or challenge myself too much
as opposed to loading an episode of a
show that was actually good it's the
same reason why sometimes a 20-minute
anime episode sounds like a massive
investment yet somehow I have no problem
clicking on an hour-long Mario Sunshine
speedrun that hour just put on in the
background while I do some holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm 30 minutes in and I've just sat
here watching it all well nothing this
far in Mars well watched no 30 minutes I
truly value finding anime that gives me
new experiences great storytelling
unique ideas and just losing myself in a
show and if you're getting into this
medium as well I implore you to go out
of your comfort zone because you'll
probably discover something completely
new you had no idea you'd like but there
are also times when I just want to shut
my brain up and watch some black haired
generic Kirito looking mane cow
overpower a bunch of dudes once you
accept that you won't be able to see
everything you start feeling less
overwhelmed and anxious about optimizing
how to spend your free time and just
doing things you actually feel like
because let's be honest you're always
going to be behind you're always gonna
have another anime you have to watch or
another game you have to play and once
you get around to finally finishing that
show there are 10 more that have been
added to your list in the time you took
to finish it so if it's gonna be like
that anyway [ __ ] it give me those big
titty anime girls thirsting over Nathan
no personality let me relax - another
mindless Issei Kai in between my
viewings of legends of the Galactic
Heroes hey maybe even give that old
anime a rewatch instead of feeling
pressure to always have to watch
something new there's too much [ __ ] out
there right now for you to be doing
something you don't enjoy and the last
thing you should be doing is stressing
over your [ __ ] entertainment
I guess all I'm trying to say is guys
don't worry I'll watch for Metal
Alchemist one day seriously let me just
watch a bit more of SEO though and maybe
finish Assassin's fried alright and just
one more Issei Kai hey guys hope you
enjoyed that video I know this was a bit
more rambley than my usual fare I just
wanted to try something a bit different
and just chill a bit and write down the
contents of my mind without too much
thought into the structure and you know
just have a casual chat with you or if
you did like it then leave a comment and
who knows maybe I'll make more videos
like this as that said thank you very
much to BD D in your life
Walt Oh Nikolas Tatum Mike elfin sisters
one zero zero eight six Ella four and
everyone else on page one for supporting
me this month and helped me to not watch
Full Metal Alchemist you can also join
in hurling abuse at me for not watching
your favorite anime by checking out my
patreon if you'd like it's coming up to
not only the end of the year again but
it's gonna be the end of the decade and
I have some content plans for just that
so hope you look forward to it until
then though no further updates today
I've been Gigot and I'll see you all
next time